vous propose de
commencer aujourd'hui les travaux de
notre commission d'enquête avec
l'audition du Conseil supérieur du
notariat qui est représenté par deux
notaires maître François Devaux
directeur des affaires juridiques et
mettre Frédéric Violot membre de la
section droit immobilier de l'Institut
des études juridiques du Conseil
supérieur du notariat mettre la loi
climat et résilience a imposé il y a
deux ans maintenant un calendrier très
exigeant pour conduire à la rénovation
des logements la plus connue et
l'introduction de l'indécence
énergétique qui s'impose au logement
locatif les plus énergivores les G plus
depuis cette année puis en 2025 2028 et
2034 au logement
GFE à partir de cette année s'impose
également l'audit énergétique pour les
immeubles en mono-propriété classée G
avant de s'étendre là aussi dans un
avenir proche ce calendrier se fonde sur
l'opposabilité du DPE qui suscite
pourtant bon nombre d'interrogations
quant à sa fiabilité
d'autres mesures encore modifient la
prise en compte de la rénovation dans
les copropriétés à travers le DPE
collectif l'instauration d'un diagnostic
technique global et d'un programme
pluriannuel de travaux la Commission
voudrait donc savoir comment en tant
qu'expert de l'immobilier du patrimoine
vous appréhendez ce calendrier et
l'ensemble de ces obligations
cette nouvelle réglementation
conduit-elle les propriétaires à retirer
leur bien du marché de la location soit
en les vendant ou en les consacrant à la
location saisonnière
s'agit-il d'un phénomène d'ampleur qui
doit susciter l'inquiétude pour la
stabilité du marché du logement doit-on
craindre la création d'un marché gris de
la location
quel est l'impact de ces mesures sur le
marché immobilier y a-t-il un signal
prix significatif à la hausse ou à la
baisse selon l'étiquette énergétique
est-ce que cela dépend de la typologie
des biens ou des zones géographiques
comment peut-on aider les propriétaires
bailleurs et quel serait selon vous les
mesures fiscales les plus efficaces
il semble que la rénovation soit en
panne dans les copropriétés certains
pointent les modalités les décisions en
assemblée générale comment selon vous le
cadre législatif pourrait-il évoluer
enfin la loi climat est résilience a
voulu relancer le financement de travaux
via des prêts hypothécaires en l'espèce
le prêt avance rénovation quel est votre
avis sur ce dispositif pourquoi ne
fonctionne ne fonctionne-t-il pas avant
de vous laisser la parole pour répondre
à ses premières questions il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'un
compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible
des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende aussi Maître je
vous invite l'un après l'autre après tes
serments de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité a levé la main droite et à
dire je le jure
je jure de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité je promets de dire toute la
vérité
merci je vous remercie de vous prêter à
ce formalisme qui est propre à notre aux
commissions d'enquête je vous laisse
donc maintenant la parole pour répondre
déjà à ces quelques questions et ensuite
monsieur le rapporteur et nos collègues
qui sont ici présents pour cette
audition pourront également bien sûr
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions complémentaires c'est à vous
madame la sénatrice nous sommes très
honorés d'être présent parmi vous avez
évoqué dans vos premiers propos nos
propos introductifs
l'opposabilité du DPE et la manière dont
il a considérablement évolué dans un
laps de temps qui est très court puisque
si on regarde un peu plus derrière nous
on s'aperçoit que le DPE existait depuis
2006 il s'est passé une quinzaine
d'années sans que véritablement
il soit impactant sur le plan
réglementaire sur le plan législatif sur
le plan coercitif et sur le plan de son
opposabilité comme vous l'avez dit et
les choses ont évolué assez subitement
au 1er juillet 2021 lorsqu'il a été
considérablement réformé
les notaires se sont rendus compte sur
le terrain de l'incidence
de cette réforme sur le plan du marché
sur les conséquences comportementales
également que ça a pu engendrer dans
l'esprit du consommateur immobilier qui
soit vendeur ou qu'il soit acquéreur
nous avons très vite été sollicités par
les journalistes sur ce sujet qui
cherchait comme vous l'avez dit à
déterminer si
l'avènement de ces nouvelles règles
allait avoir pour conséquence de
soit bloquer le marché on a à peu près
tout entendu sur ce sujet soit au
contraire générer une accélération
absolument invraisemblable de des ventes
de biens énergivores qu'il fallait
impérativement brader avant que les
premiers termes surviennent et notamment
le 1er janvier 2023 pour les logements
dont la consommation énergétique en
énergie finale et supérieure à 450 kWh
par mètre carré par an
le constat qu'on peut en faire sur le
plan du marché
nous a pris un petit peu de temps car il
nous fallait tout simplement prendre la
mesure de cet impact sur nos
statistiques immobilières puisque vous
savez que nous sommes très attentifs à
sleek nous les analysons avec avec
l'Insee ce qu'on peut en dire
aujourd'hui
c'est qu'effectivement le nombre de
transactions immobilières des biens
qu'on va considérer comme étant
énergivore c'est à dire catégorie F ou G
à augmenter de manière relativement
significative
pour reprendre les chiffres qui sont en
notre possession et pour faire un
comparatif de pertinence entre le
troisième trimestre 2021 c'est à dire le
début de l'entrée en vigueur du nouveau
DPE et les derniers chiffres dont nous
disposons concrètement la fin de l'année
2022 cette augmentation est tout à fait
mesurable
concrètement pour les biens catégoriés
en G nous sommes passés entre ces deux
termes de 3% du volume de vente à
environ 8%, c'est donc suffisamment
important pour être noté et quand on
regarde les biens classés en F on note
aussi une augmentation un peu moins
sensible mais néanmoins perceptible qui
nous fait aussi les de 8 à 11%. il faut
toutefois être
prudent dans cette approche statistique
qui est un petit peu
perverti parce qu'on appellerait le
droit transitoire c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à
une situation d'analyse statistique où
on est amené à cumuler et à comparer des
choses qui ne sont pas forcément
comparables pourquoi parce que on a
encore la possibilité aujourd'hui de
muter un bien immobilier en produisant
en diagnostic de performance énergétique
qui est de l'ancienne génération c'est à
dire d'avant le premier juillet 2021 et
ceci durera désormais jusqu'à la fin de
l'année prochaine donc ce droit
transitoire parasite un petit peu la
qualité de l'analyse en ce sens que il
nous amène à mélanger des données qui ne
sont pas qui ne sont pas homogènes
deuxièmement les paramètres ayant changé
on se retrouve également potentiellement
avec un nombre de biens énergivores plus
important ce qui veut dire que cette
augmentation des volumes peut tout à la
fois traduire effectivement un
comportement de la part de vendeurs qui
ont cherché à se débarrasser entre
guillemets plus vite d'un bien
immobilier qui ne l'ont pas envie de
rénover mais c'est aussi peut-être tout
simplement la volumétrie du nombre de
biens ainsi cat qui a augmenté et
aujourd'hui nous sommes pas capables de
quantifier ce qui relève du premier ou
du second paramètre donc on sent une
tendance on la perçoit dans nos études
on a cette impression assez claire que
beaucoup de vendeurs faute de moyens
faute d'envie bon pas forcément avoir
effectivement l'initiative des travaux
et vont préférer muter ses biens là mais
il ne faut pas déduire de ces chiffres
là en valeur absolue en tout cas une
augmentation littérale du volume de
transaction il faudrait pour être plus
précis neutraliser les diagnostics de
l'ancienne génération c'est un sujet sur
lequel on reviendra peut-être si vous
nous en donnez l'occasion parce que nous
pensons conseils supérieur du notariat
qu'il faudrait que cette période
transitoire soit
écourtée assez rapidement
et puis et puis voilà se donner le aussi
le moyen de faire la part des choses
entre ce que sont ce qu'est le nombre de
passoires énergétiques avant d'entrer en
vigueur de la et ce qu'il serait
aujourd'hui ça c'est un chiffre qu'il
faudrait pouvoir déterminer pour être
davantage en capacité d'apprécier la
réalité de ce de ce phénomène on a le
chiffre antérieur on savait selon les
données qui étaient produites par le
ministère de la transition écologique et
communication avait été faite sur ce
point qu'on comptait environ 4 millions
800000 passoires énergétiques
c'est-à-dire que la CFG sur à peu près
36 millions de logements en France on
pense que ce chiffre a augmenté si on le
projette sur les les résultats des
nouveaux DPE ce qui n'était pas
l'objectif des pouvoirs publics
l'objectif était de conserver le même
nombre de passoires énergétiques mais de
translater en quelque sorte 800 000
logements environ de de ceux de ces
logements qui étaient énergivores
classées électriquement et puis de les
remplacer entre guillemets c'était
l'intention primitive en tout cas par
des logements qui n'étaient pas des
passoires énergétiques là c'est classé
au dessus de de F et G qui était chauffé
gaz et électrique et fioul et en fait
cette translation là c'est pas opéré
cette façon-ci et voilà il faudrait que
ces chiffres là puissent être mis à jour
pour qu'on ait un peu plus de clarté là
dessus
en ce qui concerne
l'impact de
la classification des biens sur les prix
elle est aujourd'hui mesurée
donc essentiellement des logements qui
sont mis à la vente est-ce que vous
constatez aussi que ça amène plus de
propriétaires à louer leurs biens de
façon saisonnière plutôt que de
continuer de location longue durée
pardon nous avons des difficultés
aujourd'hui à mesurer précisément ces
chiffres là parce que
le l'analyse des chiffres locatifs ne
fait pas partie de notre de notre seul
sphère de compétence donc on n'est pas
capable d'agglomérer des statistiques
pertinentes en matière de location même
si on a des services de gestion
immobilière alors que pour la
transaction on dispose de ce de cette
faculté mais c'est effectivement une
tendance ou une réaction qu'on entend de
nos clients qui consiste à se dire bon
bien finalement puisque j'ai un cavalier
qui me permet via la location meublée de
de sortir d'être sous les écrans radars
je vais y réfléchir sérieusement on peut
pas exclure cette possibilité et
nous pensons que la proposition de loi
qui a été déposée au mois de février
dernier visant justement à homogénéiser
finalement la réglementation en
transposant la décence aux locations
meublée y compris de courte durée serait
un bon moyen d'endiguer cette déviance
qui est tout à fait tout à fait possible
le deuxième risque le marché gris dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure il peut
résulter de ça il peut résulter
effectivement d'un dévoiement
réglementaire ou législatif où on va
faire du meublé par voilà à tout craint
oui tout à fait par volonté de ce
soustraire aux obligations et puis on
peut craindre aussi que le principe ne
suffisent pas à lui-même ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que une fois qu'il est
indiqué que le logement est indécent et
qu'il est effectivement proclamé qu'il
est impossible de le louer
impossible ça dépend pour qui c'est à
dire que ce marché gris peut aussi
se traduire par des comportements de
bailleurs qui finalement
ne se priveront pas de louer alors ça
c'est un c'est un comportement qu'on ne
verra pas parce que par définition celui
qui voudra louer dans ces conditions-là
ne viendra évidemment pas voir son
notaire sans quoi il aurait quelques
soucis mais on ne pourra pas le mesurer
pour autant ce sera ce sera tout à fait
possible et malheureusement trouvera
bien des gens qui seront prêts à louer
dans ces conditions-là parce que ils
pourront quand même accéder à un
logement qui ne sera pas celui dont ils
ont envie mais qui voilà économiquement
leur sera malgré tout accessible donc
c'est un risque qu'il ne faut pas
négliger de notre point de vue et vous
le savez certainement les sanctions
aujourd'hui qui sont attachées à l'un
des sens du logement ne nous semble pas
être de nature à répondre à ce nouveau
critère d'indécence qui est le caractère
énergivor du logement pourquoi parce
essentiellement les sanctions attachées
à l'indécence se traduisent en réalité
par le droit commun des contrats c'est
la possibilité de demander un juge de
revoir le loyer c'est la possibilité de
remettre en cause le bail mais par
définition celui qui acceptera le louer
dans ces conditions là sera évidemment
privé de cette possibilité puisque tout
ce qui l'intéressera ce sera de louer
aux conditions qu'on voudra bien lui
proposer donc il y a un risque qui est
relativement fort aussi à ce titre là le
marché gris ça peut être ces deux
comportements là
voyons
l'incidence c'est un des sujets que vous
évoquiez l'incidence de la performance
énergétique sur le prix est également
mesuré par nos statisticiens c'est un
sujet qui nous intéresse depuis un
certain nombre d'années on a on était un
peu précurseur sur cette question de la
valeur verte sur laquelle nous avons
communiqué bien avant la réforme du DPE
nous disposons donc de chiffres qui nous
permettent effectivement de mesurer
l'incidence de la performance
énergétique sur le prix de marché la
technique statistique qui est employée
est assez est assez simple nous prenons
comme référence le gros du marché
immobilier de l'ancien c'est-à-dire la
classe D qui jusqu'à leur représentait à
peu près 40% du volume des ventes dans
l'ancien alors c'est un chiffre qui est
un petit peu baissé justement à la
faveur des logements énergivores et des
chiffres que j'ai énonçais tout à
l'heure l'idée étant de regarder
de combien de pour cent un bien va se
vendre
en plus ou moins selon qu'il est très
mal classé ou très bien classé ça se
mesure ça se mesure de façon assez
logique avec des écarts types assez
symétriques entre les biens
très bien classés et ceux qui sont très
mal classés avec des écarts types en
symétrie de l'ordre plus neuf plus 10 %
voire même davantage sur les biens qui
sont classés A et B et à l'inverse on va
se retrouver avec -9 - 10 - 15
quelquefois en fonction des régions sur
les biens qui sont très mal classés cela
étant c'est une c'est une indication de
marché qui est intéressante et qui
devient petit à petit dans l'inconscient
collectif un marqueur ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que nos candidats à
l'acquisition aujourd'hui examine le
diagnostic de performance énergétique
alors que il faut être tout à fait
honnête les 15 premières années de de
son de sa vie c'était pas vraiment le
sujet qui passionnait les foules il faut
quand même le dire aujourd'hui c'est un
outil de négociation qui est tout à fait
avérée et évidemment
l'opposabilité le caractère plus
objectif du DPE contribue à cela et on
le voit bien aujourd'hui on communique
sur le diagnostic de performance
énergétique dès le stade de l'annonce et
nos clients ils sont de plus en plus
sensibles
toutefois c'est incidence sur les prix
doit être un petit peu moduler là encore
pour plusieurs raisons de plusieurs
paramètres le premier c'est le zonage
géographique on va être évidemment plus
sensible à la performance énergétique
d'un logement à Cambrai qu'à Nice
et réglementairement d'ailleurs on n'a
pas tort de penser ça puisque en réalité
l'incidence aujourd'hui de la
performance énergétique
c'est essentiellement la capacité à
chauffer le moins cher possible ou en
tout cas de perdre le moins de chaleur
possible on ne s'intéresse en réalité
qu'au confort d'été que depuis le 1er
juillet 2021 donc c'est un c'est un
phénomène qui est tout à fait nouveau
donc dans dans l'esprit de nos de nos
clients c'est un sujet qui est encore un
peu un peu nébuleux donc localisation
géographique
tension bien entendu
plus le marché est tendu moins
l'incidence de la performance
énergétique sera forte je cherche un
logement à Paris si les performances
c'est bien s'il est pas performant c'est
bien je n'ai pas trop le choix donc je
pense que je trouve et ce que je peux
m'offrir
et puis il ne faut pas oublier un
paramètre de bon sens c'est que
corréler directement la performance
énergétique au prix c'est un raccourci
un peu rapide il faut pas oublier qu'en
général un logement qui va offrir une
performance énergétique intéressante va
être un logement qui va être rénové et
qui va donc globalement proposer
évidemment d'autres points d'attrait
qu'un logement qui lui est resté dans
son jus si vous me le permettez pendant
pendant X années alors ces écarts là
donc on je vous les ai énoncés
en prenant comme référentiel la classe D
si maintenant je j'élargi un peu le
spectre et que je regarde effectivement
les évolution des prix de vente médian
selon l'étiquette énergie entre la
Classe G et la classe AB on va quasiment
du simple double pour la maison
individuelle et c'est quasiment la même
chose pour l'appartement c'est un tout
petit peu moins vrai mais enfin c'est
quand même le sujet on est quand même en
train de parler d'un écart -type entre
le plus performant et le moins
performant de division par deux
quasiment
je pense que sur le point marché
est-ce que vous voulez d'autres
précisions sur ce l'aspect marché en
tant que tal
de toute façon
on complétera et puis
ok
vous semblerait
[Musique]
ils comprennent quand vous leur parlez
2028 c'est déjà un peu plus nébuleux et
quand vous leur parlez 2034 là c'est la
science-fiction donc je crois que le ce
calendrier là ne les ne les effraie pas
plus que ça et je pense que
effectivement le premier janvier 2023
est arrivé assez vite bien entendu
je crois que sur le calendrier on doit
on doit se donner les moyens de cette
ambition et il faut l'assumer en tant
que tel on peut peut-être simplement
déplorer un manque de pédagogie dans la
présentation du diagnostic de
performance énergétique qui n'a été
corrigé que très récemment avec cette
distinction vous le savez entre
l'énergie primaire et l'énergie finale
qui risque d'engendrer une
incompréhension voire même peut-être des
erreurs de jugement de la part de nos
clients avec des DPE qui présentent une
énergie primaire qui les placerait
potentiellement en deçà de la Classe G
alors qu'en réalité le petit exercice
mathématique de détermination de
l'énergie finale repousse la lecture
jusqu'à la page 3 du DPE nous
permettrait de nous apercevoir que en
réalité on est complètement
on est en sécurité juridique donc là il
y a un souci de présentation les
notaires essaient de faire preuve de
pédagogie sur le sujet bon c'est un peu
technique il suffit de l'expliquer à nos
clients et puis ils finissent par le
comprendre mais c'est un petit souci un
petit souci de présentation formelle qui
évidemment d'autant plus important que
le logement est chauffé électriquement
c'est sur ce sur ce point là que le
delta entre entre le l'énergie finale et
l'énergie primaire et le plus et le plus
problématique
alors s'agissant des mesures
d'accompagnement
beaucoup beaucoup de discussions nous ne
sommes pas les seuls à nous être
exprimés sur le sujet autour de
l'émergence du statut d'un bailleur
privé la généralisation de ce que
pourrait être
le dispositif de Normandie
nous avions imaginé il y a quelques
temps de proposer des dispositions qui
permettaient effectivement de
généraliser le dispositif de Normandie
en majorant celui-ci c'est-à-dire en
augmentant le taux d'amortissement
si la preuve était rapportée
soit que on allait faire des travaux de
rénovation énergétique majeurs dans le
but d'obtenir une rénovation performante
donc essayez de mettre en évidence une
rénovation globale du bâti parce qu'on
sait que seuls celle-ci est réellement
efficiente soit également une majoration
du taux d'amortissement si on prenait
l'engagement de louer à des conditions
financières de loyer et de revenus nous
plaçons en phase avec certains minimums
sociaux dans l'esprit de ce qui a pu
exister il y a quelques années avec le
borlo-social par exemple
donc ça faisait partie des pistes de
réflexion que que nous avions imaginé
nous avions également imaginé de nous
avions proposé par amendement dans la
loi climat est résilience qui ne sont
pas restés mais qu'on a voté ici je le
sais bien je le sais bien c'est pour ça
que je commence par ça et puis on
imaginait également de d'augmenter le le
du prêt à taux zéro donc permettre
d'emprunter plus et donc plus longtemps
parce que il s'agit évidemment toujours
la même chose de garantir la solvabilité
du ménage à ce sujet là et le prêt à
taux zéro pour être un outil très fort
en termes de communication
et il faudrait qu'il nous pensons qu'il
pourrait être intéressant
que sa généralisation va justement
permettre de financer des travaux plus
importants toujours dans cette même idée
d'aller vers de la rénovation globale et
bien entendu ça se traduirait par une
augmentation de sa durée sans quoi voilà
pour les jeunes générations
l'équation peut pas être peut pas être
satisfaite
nous avons plutôt accueilli d'un bon œil
le principe du doublement du déficit
foncier qu'il est encore en termes
d'affichage est un marqueur assez fort
très très parlant pour pour le
contribuable on considère que
l'intention est louable il est
ce dispositif génère peut-être une une
difficulté technique qu'on n'a pas qu'on
apprend vraiment creusé mais sur
laquelle il faudrait peut-être qu'on
s'apesantisse un petit peu c'est que le
doublement du seuil du déficit foncier
en ce qu'il est imputable sur le revenu
global n'est pas une option c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas choisir
à l'inverse de ne pas en faire usage et
en revanche de progroger la déduction
des travaux uniquement à concurrence de
ces revenus fonciers sur les années
ultérieures
et il est possible que pour certains
contribuables ce soit finalement un
calcul plus satisfaisant il aurait
peut-être été intéressant voilà d'aller
au bout de sa réflexion là pour voir si
cette alternative là pourrait pas avoir
du sens aussi
donc ça ce serait peut-être un sujet à
creuser
c'est ça c'est un effet de bord
une petite difficulté technique
ce qu'on avait proposé et le congé pour
réaliser des travaux d'économie
d'énergie qui a été censurée par le
Conseil constitutionnel au titre de
l'article 45 un cavalier législatif oui
qui semble quand même à notre grand
désarroi
ça faisait partie des propositions de la
profession également qui avaient été
relayée par les notaires du Grand Paris
il y a quelques années j'imagine que
vous en ayez eu connaissance c'était un
rapport qui avait été fait par les les
notaires du Grand Paris en 2021 et qui
est effectivement proposé
d'instaurer en tant que motif légitime
et sérieux le congé donné au locataire
avec évidemment toutes les anti
juridique de son relogement pendant la
période de travaux et de sa
réintégration au terme de leur de leur
réalisation un petit peu à l'instar de
ce qui se passe sur le motif légitime
lié à la déconstruction reconstruction
ce qu'est un petit peu l'idée de
transposer en fait
cette mécanique pour protéger le
locataire et rendre ses travaux-là
possibles donc une proposition avait été
faite en ce sens avait été émise par par
la profession avec évidemment un
logement temporaire dans des conditions
géographiques qui étaient qui étaient
juste
oui oui c'est c'est vrai que la
réalisation de ces travaux là suppose
effectivement que les entreprises soient
au rendez-vous que les devis puissent
être produits rapidement qu'il n'y ait
pas d'effet de d'effet de vague
financière autour de ce qui est rendu
nécessaire par la réglementation alors
là c'est un sujet qui nous échappe un
peu malheureusement mais nos clients
constatent aussi des difficultés à
obtenir voilà obtenir des entreprises
des entreprises qui vont être je dirais
raisonnable dans leur tarification qui
vont être compétentes en termes de
labellisation et qui vont donc être à
même de répondre à cette préoccupation
là ça c'est un c'est un retour de
terrain qu'on a assez régulièrement
sur d'autres mesures susceptibles de
favoriser oui
sur la rénovation
dans les copropriétés comment
grosse difficulté grosse difficulté de
je pense de compréhension de
mobilisation des fonds
des choses ont été faites vous l'avez
souligné au travers du plan pluriel de
travaux au travers désormais du fléchage
du Fonds travaux vers les travaux de
rénovation énergétique
également nous considérons que toute
mesure susceptibles de de limiter en
tout cas de diminuer les seuils de
majorité
permettent évidemment de contribuer à la
à la rénovation des copropriétés mais on
nous constatons effectivement des points
de blocage relativement important
oui c'est c'est ce sont très souvent des
problèmes générationnels des problèmes
de de confrontation de de propriété
occupants et de propriétaires non
occupants
ces temps cela justement que
l'appréhension de règles de majorité
diminuée permet peut permettre de faire
passer voilà de passer d'un côté de
passer d'un côté à l'autre mais oui le
le copropriétés sont en train de prendre
beaucoup de retard et on a bien du mal à
imaginer ce qui pourrait permettre de
rendre ceci possible sauf à sauf à
envisager des de voilà des mesures de
contraintes ou des mesures de portage
qui seraient extrêmement consommatrices
de finances publiques donc c'est un
sujet qui est quand même extrêmement
délicat c'est
sur le logement on arrive à fléchir les
choses sur la copropriété c'est beaucoup
plus difficile
sur le une mesure mise en place
par la loi climat est résilience la
possibilité pour le locataire de de
proposer à son bailleur de réaliser les
travaux d'amélioration
c'est une mesure qui nous semble très
positive très positif très bonne le mode
opératoire nous paraît pertinent les
droits du bailleur sont préservés il a
la capacité de réagir mais à partir du
moment où il a une bonne raison de
réagir donc je pense que le le sens le
sens des prérogatifs de chacun est
respecté
on aurait peut-être un moyen d'améliorer
l'efficience de ce dispositif si on
offrait au locataire la possibilité de
bénéficier finalement des mêmes aides
d'État que celles dont bénéficierait le
propriétaire s'il était à l'initiative
de ces mêmes travaux
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui sur le
papier ce dispositif est satisfaisant
rien rien ne permettra de de se poser à
ça évidemment mais au final on est quand
même en train de dire que le locataire
va devoir prendre la charge de travaux
qui de par la loi est de manière tout à
fait claire relève normalement de la
responsabilité de la charge du bailleur
donc déjà on a un locataire qui est
quand même
vertueux c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et il est d'autant plus vertueux
qui sera pas aussi bien pris en charge
que sont d'ailleurs s'il prenait la
peine d'être diligent ce qui est quand
même un peu dommage et je pense que la
transposition des aides du propriétaire
vers le locataire qui déciderait de
prendre les choses en main serait un bon
moyen serait un signal fort
éventuellement avec
travailler aussi sur la durée du bail ou
bien même les modalités de résiliation
de la part du bailleur pour maintenir
effectivement une durée peut-être plus
favorable le locataire surtout dans les
zones tendus
oui autre mesure qui avait été proposée
également par les notaires sur le droit
de surplomb alors vous allez évidemment
nous dire que des choses ont déjà été
mises en place bien entendu mais
peut-être a-t-on été un peu trop timoré
dans un souci loi qui est évidemment
voilà la protection puis la protection
des droits du du propriétaire aussi du
propriétaire voisin
l'idée émise par les notaires était
était de faire de ce droit de surplomb
un droit d'ordre public une sorte de
servitude d'utilité publique qui aurait
permis tout à la fois le surplomb du
domaine public lorsque celui-ci est
nécessaire l'isolation d'un pignon qui
surplombe un trottoir par exemple mais
qui aurait aussi permis d'imposer
finalement à un voisin des travaux
d'isolation pas forcément limitée à la
hauteur de 2 mètres qui de notre point
de vue n'est pas n'est pas forcément
satisfaisante en terme déficience des
travaux certainement rendre certaines
certaines rénovation impossible ou
inefficaces et le fait de systématiser
cela en lui donnant effectivement une
vocation de servitude d'utilité publique
qui répondrait parfaitement en objective
d'intérêt général donc ça de notre point
de vue ça peut tout à fait s'écrire pour
être un moyen de donner plus de force et
de fluidifier peut-être ces aspects
réglementaires de droit de surplomb
parce que c'est effectivement en
pratique l'isolation par l'extérieur qui
est un qui est un sujet très très
fréquent et qui sera un sujet notamment
dans les dans les copropriétés
et dans les mitoyenneté de de toutes
sortes d'immeubles donc le rendre le
rendre plus fort ce droit de surplomb
pour être pertinent
je regarde si on avait pointé d'autres
d'autres dispositions
[Musique]
vous pouvez préavancer rénovation vous
avez raison on constate non ça ne marche
pas
franchement pas travailler cette
question mais on peut vous revenir sur
ce sujet là on va essayer de déterminer
ce qui on n'a pas de retour là dessus
mais c'est c'est un désert on n'a pas de
aucun
penser que c'est le secteur bancaire qui
qui n'est pas qui est frigo la matière
ou qui c'est possible c'est possible
mais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
d'analyse ou à ma connaissance il y a
pas d'analyse des points de blocage on
comprend pas ce qui se passe je ne sais
pas si effectivement les banques le
proposent aux clients ce sont peut-être
elles qu'il faudrait commencer par
interpeller sur cette question là
les banques sont devenues sensibles à la
performance énergétique puisqu'il n'est
désormais pas rare que la banque nous
demande la production du diagnostic de
performance énergétique avant d'étudier
même le contrat de prêt donc ça fait
partie du scoring aujourd'hui et ça fait
partie je dirais de la mesure du risque
de la banque c'est à dire que dans un
marché qui était ces dernières années
assez impressionnistes
la question que se pose évidemment le
banquier c'est la réalité de sa créance
versus la valeur de son gage donc
forcément
j'analyse une passoire thermique qui est
vendue au prix fort est-ce que j'ai
est-ce que je suis en risque ou pas par
rapport à au recouvrement éventuel de la
dette c'est un c'est un vrai sujet pour
eux donc on peut le comprendre mais on
n'a pas de retour pas de retour marché
sur
on n'a rien de tangible à vous dire à ce
sujet là ce qu'on constate en revanche
c'est que c'est le désert
j'en ai pas vu passer un et je ne sais
pas si
donc c'est rien rien
d'approfondir ce sujet
peut-être monsieur rapporteur
oui merci
pour
déjà un grand nombre de un grand nombre
de questions avec avec précision moi
j'avais peut-être sur
la réflexion qu'on peut avoir et on sait
que ça a été une vraie réflexion dans
les dans les choix quand on a auditionné
les différents ministres sur le fait de
rendre obligatoire en tout cas la
rénovation la rénovation thermique soit
la location c'est ce qui a été choisi du
coup et donc ce qui est mis ce qui est
mis en place
soit la vente
pourrait être les deux d'ailleurs mais
en tout cas la réflexion de rendre
obligatoire à la vente
et de rendre obligatoire c'est ces
travaux donc quand il y a une quand il y
a une session donc du coup avoir votre
avis du coup justement sur ce dispositif
là sur le dispositif en fait qui
pourrait s'apparenter un petit peu à ce
qui se passe déjà sur
l'assainissement individuel ou en fait
on a l'obligation du coup de mise en
conformité donc cette obligation elle se
fait à la vente et la possibilité
justement de pouvoir garder le montant
en tout cas quand il y a une quand il y
a une vente alors
en tout cas dans le principe et qui
puisse ensuite obliger en tout cas
permettre à faire les à faire les
travaux est-ce que ce type de
d'orientation en tout cas de dispositif
pourrait voilà pour y trouver sa place
sur la question de la rénovation la
rénovation thermique on a aussi
poursuit là-dessus parce que ça va dans
le dans le même sens on avait auditionné
plusieurs propositions sur les prix
hypothécaires et donc sur aussi l'idée
de dire qu'en fait on pourrait avoir un
prêt qui soit dans l'hypothèque soit sur
la valeur de la maison
du logement et de l'habitation et ce qui
permettrait d'avoir en fait un
prêt sur du très long terme avec une
hypothèque du coup sur la valeur de la
maison et qui soit remboursé donc dans
les propositions qu'il y avait été un
remboursement à la vente pareil à la
session et donc du coup de pouvoir
rembourser via un fond qui serait mis en
place de pouvoir rembourser le la valeur
des travaux enfin la valeur du prêt à
possession ou alors au bout de 30 ans
c'était en tout cas dans les dans les
propositions qui avaient l'intérêt en
fait de
à la fois de pouvoir financer à de
manière assez massivement et de sortir
du système de subvention etc à d'aide et
donc d'avoir voilà vraiment un système
de prêts
en fonction de ce qui était le bien en
tant que tel et du coup de sa rénovation
énergétique par ailleurs avec une
mécanique qui est assez comparable à
celle qu'on a pu connaître avec le Pass
Foncier par exemple c'est le terme qui
me revient à l'esprit la technique qui
me revient à l'esprit où on différait
finalement le transfert de propriété du
sol et donc le paiement de son prix
au remboursement primitif de la maison
la question que vous posez est d'autant
plus d'actualité que l'Union européenne
s'en est emparée comme vous le savez et
que
il est donc question désormais de mettre
en place un dispositif
d'interdiction de vendre si un certain
niveau de performance énergétique n'est
pas atteint et peut-être d'imposer une
une sanction sous la forme d'une décote
qui serait appliquée au prix de vente et
vous avez raison de souligner le
parallèle avec les travaux de mise en
conformité de
l'installation d'assainissement
individuel puisque c'est une mécanique
qui a déjà eu à être traitée à cette
occasion là
nous ne sommes pas favorables à ce qui
serait de nature à bloquer une vente du
fait de d'un seuil de performance
énergétique insuffisant
nous pensons que ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes économiques des
problèmes de marché également de
problèmes juridique au regard de ce
qu'est le droit de propriété ces sujets
là avaient effectivement déjà été évoqué
sur les installations d'assainissement
individuel
et finalement avait été écarté à la
faveur d'un dispositif qui est un petit
peu plus souple puisque aujourd'hui ce
que dit la loi c'est que lorsqu'une
non-conformité est constatée l'acquéreur
dispose d'un délai d'un an pour
effectuer les travaux de mise en
conformité prescrits par le rapport
avec il faut bien le reconnaître même si
c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui une
certaine souplesse
des services publics d'assainissement
collectif et des collectivités locales
sur l'application à la lettre de ce
dispositif toutefois nous sommes tout à
fait persuadés que à un moment donné
cette souplesse cessera et que on mettra
effectivement les acquéreurs en face de
cette responsabilité qu'ils ont accepté
d'endosser et c'est une responsabilité
qui est d'autant plus problématique pour
nous qu'il nous faut aussi entendre
professionnelle l'appréhender avec
toutes les garanties et toutes les
sécurités requises c'est à dire que
concrètement
se trouver face à une situation où
on se on se retrouverait à dire et bien
voilà l'installation n'est pas conforme
monsieur l'acquéreur vous en faites
votre affaire personnelle sans recours
contre le vendeur ça revient un petit
peu à vous demander de me faire un
chèque en blanc quoi ce que vous auriez
peut-être un peu de mal à faire je pense
et bien c'est ce qu'on est en train
quelquefois de de suggérer à nos clients
donc nous devons nous sécuriser les
contrats quand on est face à cette
situation là en attirant l'attention de
l'acquéreur sur le fait que tôt ou tard
il lui sera demandé de se mettre aux
normes que cette mise en or aura un coup
et qu'il serait quand même bien inspiré
de quantifier ce coup de façon précise
avant de délivrer son accord sur la
chose et sur le prix
je relate tout cela parce que je pense
que la mécanique est exactement la même
et l'approche pour être tout à fait
comparable sur la performance
énergétique c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
il me semble assez délicat de séquestrer
ou de bloquer un montant forfaitaire
mais il me semble tout aussi délicat de
dire à l'acquéreur qui se débrouille de
tout ça sans être en capacité de
chiffrer ce que coûterait la mise en
conformité on va dire ça comme ça
conformité énergétique de son logement
c'est à cela que sert le diagnostic de
performance énergétique dans une moindre
mesure c'est un outil d'alerte c'est un
simple outil d'alerte qui a le mérite
d'exister mais on sait très bien qu'il
ne va pas assez loin et que c'est
l'audit énergétique selon la
monopropriété qui nous permet d'avoir de
disposer d'un chiffrage un peu plus
précis
nous sommes assez nombreux à considérer
à ce sujet que il ne serait pas incongru
de ce fait et pour garantir la sécurité
juridique de l'acquéreur économique
également que cette audit énergétique
soit généralisée c'est à dire que ce qui
nous semblerait davantage de nature à
préserver les droits de l'acquéreur et à
atteindre l'objectif ce serait que le
paramètre de la performance énergétique
et du coup de la rénovation du logement
devienne un paramètre de discussion du
prix
on pense que ça va être quand même très
compliqué de le faire autrement il
existe également des obstacles
juridiques c'est à dire que séquestrer
une partie du prix pour imposer au
vendeur de réaliser les travaux avant de
vendre ça pose un problème déjà c'est
que il faut il faut claquer le vendeur
dispose des fonds nécessaires par
définition si on séquestre le prix les a
pas donc on fait comment et puis ça
s'appelle une vente d'immeuble à rénover
le contrat dans lequel un vendeur
s'oblige à faire des travaux après la
vente en principe c'est une vente
d'immeuble à rénover donc là on rentre
dans un cadre législatif réglementaire
d'ordre public
qui qui est sans rapport avec le
problème
pardon et quant à séquestrer un montant
théorique enfin un montant forfaitaire
là ça nous laisse également un peu
pantois parce que
les risques sont multiples alors on va
séquestrer 5% du prix alors pourquoi pas
10 pourquoi pas 6 pourquoi pas 3 bon que
fait-on de cette somme là s'il s'avère
que les travaux de rénovation
énergétique atteignent ou n'atteignent
pas ce seuil ça se passe comment et ne
risque-t-on pas et ça je pense que c'est
un personnellement je crois que c'est un
risque majeur ne risque-t-on pas
finalement de Piper les dés du marché de
manière un peu artificielle c'est à dire
qu'en clair je suis vendeur je sais que
mon bien a une performance énergétique
qui est mauvaise je vais monter ça de 5
points et puis basta
donc je ne suis pas persuadé qu'on
résolve tous les problèmes avec ça je
pense en revanche que
des obligations de quantification de
travaux de rénovation énergétique dès le
stade de la discussion sur l'accord sur
la chose et sur le prix serait de nature
à équilibrer le rapport de force et à
contraindre indirectement le vendeur à
la réalité économique parce que tous les
acquéreurs auront cette réaction et
diront ben voilà moi ça va me coûter
temps à l'horizon 2-3 ans peut-être
moins donc je baisse donc on pourrait
imaginer des obligations de travaux
corréler à un chiffrage précis qui
imposerait finalement une discussion en
amont dans la détermination du prix et
c'est pour ça que je souhaitais rappeler
que la mécanique sur le les questions de
conformité des réseaux d'assainissement
de l'assainissement individuel parce
qu'en fait c'est un peu la même c'est un
peu la même chose il faut mettre
l'acquéreur en capacité de disposer d'un
moyen de pression économique claire
et pourquoi pas aller plus loin et
généraliser à cet effet l'audit
énergétique pourquoi pas qu'est-ce qui
nous l'interdit aujourd'hui moi
personnellement je les vois pas de je
n'y vois pas d'inconvénient majeur alors
on aura évidemment vos genoux rétorqués
ça va coûter cher ça va coûter de
l'argent mais on doit oui oui on doit on
doit effectivement savoir aussi ce qu'on
veut si si c'est un objectif d'utilité
publique peut-être doit-on se donner les
moyens de le satisfaire
la fiabilisation du DPE on sait que même
si cette nouvelle version est plus
satisfaisante que que la première elle a
encore perfectible est-ce que vous vous
avez voilà une approche et des idées
là-dessus et est-ce que vous voyez
émerger un contentieux aujourd'hui déjà
au regard du DPE puisque on s'aperçoit
que sur un même bien lorsque plusieurs
DPE sont faits on peut avoir un bien qui
peut avoir une différence placé une
étiquette de de deux étiquettes voir
parfois trois et donc à un moment donné
des risques de contentieux la presse
consumériste sans effet
les échos de manière tonitruente il y a
quelques mois et pour vous dire les
choses comme je le pense ça m'avait un
petit peu agacé pourquoi parce que c'est
une réalité oui ce qui a été constaté
c'est une réalité on va pas revenir
là-dessus mais il faut quand même
souligner que
l'exercice qui consiste à normaliser 37
millions de logements qui sont tous
hétéroclites les uns par rapport aux
autres est un exercice extrêmement
périlleux
donc une fois qu'on s'est fait la
raillerie du cas de la maison de
Monsieur machin qui effectivement a eu
tantôt un diagnostic des tantôt un
diagnostic eux et qu'on a fait cet état
de fait d'accord mais qu'a-t-on de mieux
à proposer que cela finalement pas grand
chose donc je crois qu'il faut quand
même garder à l'esprit que comme vous
l'avez dit le DPE c'est renforcé il est
devenu de plus en plus objectif et nous
allons dans le bon sens alors certes
c'est pas parfait mais l'exercice est
difficile et peut-être peut-on se
permettre de dire que le temps imparti
pour le réaliser est également très
contraint là encore c'est un sujet de
moyen mais concrètement un diagnostic de
performance énergétique aujourd'hui se
facture à peu près 150 euros
le nombre de points de contrôle c'est à
peu près 150 points également
donc on comprend bien que l'équation est
quand même assez compliqué à satisfaire
sur le plan économique pour le
diagnostiqueur s'il veut éviter de
déposer le bilan il va lui falloir quand
même être particulièrement efficace dans
l'établissement de son document il n'a
pas d'autre choix que d'aller
relativement vite ce n'est pas une
analyse de bureau d'étude thermique
c'est autre chose et le risque
effectivement
probable en tout cas c'est ma conviction
et on a effectivement constaté
c'est une artificialisation de la
dégradation c'est une dégradation
artificielle c'est plutôt dans ce sens
là qu'il faut le dire une dégradation
artificielle de la performance
énergétique du parc immobilier français
c'est-à-dire que concrètement je suis
diagnostiqueur j'ai un temps contraint
pour établir mon document je fais mon
maximum pour produire le résultat le
plus objectif possible j'ai un doute sur
l'analyse de tel ou tel paramètre je ne
peux pas me permettre économiquement
d'aller au bout de l'investigation le
diagnostic de performance énergétique
métoposables je protège peut-être ma
responsabilité et je vais plutôt
dégrader tel paramètre parce que j'ai un
doute et que je ne veux pas qu'on m'en
fasse un jour le reproche donc sur ce
sujet là peut-être qu'effectivement le
mieux est l'ennemi du bien là encore
j'en reviens je tourne un peu en rond
autour de l'audit énergétique mais
voilà c'est un autre document c'est un
autre coup c'est une autre démarche mais
c'est peut-être un complément assez
logique en définitive
par ailleurs je reviens pour pour
terminer de répondre à votre question
sur
le droit transitoire aujourd'hui nous
nous trouvons dans une situation qui est
un peu complexe puisque on a écrit
d'ailleurs à ce sujet là
et on a fait des propositions
impossibilité aujourd'hui compte tenu de
l'utilisation de diagnostic ancienne
génération de connaître le champ
d'application des mentions obligatoires
dans les annonces des biens alloués ou à
vendre en cas de mono-propriété si j'ai
un diagnostic de performance énergétique
ancienne génération je ne suis pas
certain que la catégorie énergétique et
la bonne je ne suis donc
fondamentalement pas certain
de la nécessité ou pas de produire un
audit énergétique donc c'est quand même
un peu dommage et en possibilité de
définir précisément l'obligation
d'information dans les baux pour les
mêmes raisons
donc nous nous militerions plutôt en
faveur là encore d'un raccourcissement
de cette période transitoire et
finalement d'une obligation de refaire
le diagnostic de performance énergétique
c'est un problème d'utilité publique
c'est un souci majeur pour l'État c'est
une conséquence qui peut complètement
s'entendre
de notre point de vue
est-ce que nos collègues qui assistent à
l'audition auraient des questions à
poser
non
monsieur rapporteur
du coup c'est vrai que vous avez pas
totalement répondu oui oui je ne vous ai
pas répondu j'ai fait je me suis je me
suis enfui vers le pas foncier et je ne
suis jamais revenu au sujet je vous fais
de m'excuser non je pense que c'est
peut-être une idée intéressante qui est
assez finalement proche de ce que je
suggérais tout à l'heure sur le
l'allongement en dans le temps du prêt à
taux zéro c'est un peu la même idée vu
autrement effectivement une rallonge
hypothécaire liée à la rénovation et
corrélé évidemment
à la justification de la teinte de tel
ou telle ça et oui tout à fait oui c'est
là encore est-ce que des banques s'en
empareront
ça c'est
oui c'est une question de contrainte il
faut le lier il faut le lier
la contrainte sur le blocage de l'acte
de vente vous l'avez compris ne nous
paraît pas pertinente en revanche nous
pensons qu'il existe d'autres moyens de
contraintes qui permettraient de faire
bouger les choses
mais malgré tout par le marché quoi
juste du coup pour préciser quand vous
parlez de compte sur la contrainte vous
êtes plutôt en fait sur ce qui est mis
en place actuellement sur des
contraintes dans le temps en fait oui
c'est plutôt ça qui fonctionne c'est de
d'avoir des échéances comme ça que ça
soit
ce qui est mis en place ou d'autres
enfin pour avoir des contraintes
notamment sur les copropriété puisqu'on
voit que c'est là où ça bloque ce serait
plutôt dans ce sens là plutôt
effectivement d'avoir des contraintes à
la vente ou qui est absolument
ce sera je pense extrêmement mal vécu
par
par les Français enfin ça va être très
compliqué à imposer c'est le droit de
propriété est un droit important le
droit au logement est un droit
fondamental alors
évidemment on parle d'un propriétaire de
son logement donc on s'adresse déjà à
des gens qui parlent par définition sont
déjà favorisées malgré tout mais quand
même
ça pourrait être pour pour beaucoup
d'entre eux le bien de toute une vie on
peut se retrouver quand même dans des
situations qui risquent d'être
extrêmement anxiogène et extrêmement
rude c'est on pense pas que ce soit la
bonne la bonne solution j'ai oublié
au titre des mesures fiscales on avait
également imaginé une prise en charge
par l'État sous la forme d'une ristourne
des droits de mutation
à la marge c'est un sujet c'est un sujet
très très annexe mais ça pourrait être
aussi une solution
restitution de tout ou partie partie
pourquoi pas en corréler à l'ampleur des
travaux réalisés par rapport au prix
d'acquisition
évidemment sous conditions de
justification de la réalisation des
travaux dans un délai à convenir et
c'est une idée propositions du CNR non
dans ce sens il y a pas le Grand Paris
également c'est également
mais ça a été repris également les
propositions en tout cas dans ce qu'on a
pu en lire il y a une question de de
geler les DMTO pour justement permettre
ce serait pas forcément les geler mais
ce serait d'avoir effectivement une
ristourne entre guillemets c'est-à-dire
on paye les droits dans un premier temps
on s'engage à faire des travaux et ses
travaux sont réellement réalisés enfin
ce sont réalisés et conformes agréé il y
a un remboursement effectivement d'une
partie qui serait proportionnellement
autant des travaux sur le montant des
droits acquittés alors c'est c'est pas
avec ça que j'irai d'acquéreur va
forcément s'enrichir moi je trouve que
symboliquement ça peut être aussi une
contribution intéressante de la
collectivité qui a peut-être d'autres
choses aussi à faire mais enfin bon
voilà c'était aussi un complément aussi
il faut que ce soit donnant-donnant par
rapport par rapport à ça c'est une
illustration intéressante aussi dans le
le geste dans la communication
c'est c'est oui ça c'est un autre sujet
mais je là c'est un aparté
aujourd'hui la presse tendance à
présenter les dispositions destinées à
favoriser la rénovation énergétique du
bâti uniquement sous l'angle coercitif
et je nous notaire nous devons et on
essaie de on s'y force quand même
rappeler aussi à nos clients tous les
jours que il ne s'agit pas que de
sanctions il existe aussi déjà quand
même des outils des moyens alors qui
peuvent être optimisés on a on a jeté
quelques pistes aujourd'hui mais il faut
que nous ayons se soucis de voilà de
communication aussi du de la virtuosité
du système et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
un ensemble de punitions tout ça va dans
le bon sens donc on essaie de de
également de présenter les choses sous
cet angle là au quotidien c'est
important
juste pour être complet si tu me permets
on a travaillé en travaillant encore des
propositions en matière de donation
en essayant de corréler le système et
l'allègement des droites de donation ou
alors effectivement
des abattements plus importants pour
ceux qui sont vertueux et qui s'engagent
dans une justement lorsqu'il s'agit de
donation de biens immobiliers une
rénovation énergétique globale également
de la même manière conforme agréée etc
donc ça c'est aussi une piste qui est
importante c'est à dire les donations
entre guillemets n'ont pas à terme mais
a bu aussi effectivement annexe mais à
but écologique donc ça c'est aussi voilà
c'est ça on transmet quelque chose qui
est plus vertueux avec des allègements
au passage on sait aussi c'est aussi
quelque chose sur lequel on travaille
actuellement
peut-être une dernière question est-ce
que vous avez pu constater aussi au
regard de ce calendrier climat et
résilience alors bon les propriétaires
qui mettent en vente leurs biens des
propriétaires qui les gèle qui les
mettent vers la location saisonnière
est-ce que vous avez pu observer une
montée en puissance en tant que faire ce
peu du viager non non d'accord non non
on n'a pas mesuré cette c'est un micro
marché
avec l'UNPI président de l'ENPI voilà
mettait en avance cette possibilité
aussi de voir le viager peut-être se
développer dans cet environnement et
dans ce contexte oui oui il faut que je
penche pour persuader que ça génère
autant d'intention que cela en tant que
tel franchement je pense pas
l'incitation mais comme tu le dis c'est
ça reste un jour en tout cas dans les
études
très très marginal
bien écoutez s'il n'y a plus de
questions vous remercie merci de cette
audition qui était très intéressante et
on vous souhaite une bonne après-midi